what's your experience guys been with um
you know ultra success ultra successful
wealthy men and they're in their
position versus be you know plugged in
versus unplayed
same thing as broke guys for some reason
money and women
no overlap whatsoever
right
i get in trouble with this this topic
occasionally because i think a lot of
people who have a lot of money um think
that they because they have the money
that they must be doing something right
right it's it's hard to i i've dealt
with some very wealthy men in my life
um
working for and working with um the guys
that i uh the one of the guys that i
used to work with um
in uh the
the import expert in my in the liquor
business was a very wealthy guy and then
he was also kind of working with the
guys who are in the second largest
distributing company of
out you know wine and spirits and these
guys have like this that's like real
that's the first time i really
encountered like people who have like
like
society changing money or could if they
wanted to like they're pushing they're
not just like oh i've got like you know
10 million dollars in the bank account
because i'm a rock star or a movie star
something like that these guys are
moving hundreds of millions of dollars
around
and
there's a difference i i that was when i
sort of made the distinction between
wealth and like just being a rich guy
right um i have dealt with casino gms
for most of my gaming career as and then
for some very wealthy guys in um
in my other aspects of my you know my
previous career and my current career
actually um but the one thing i've
noticed amongst all of them is that
there is this
there's this presence that if i am if
i'm doing something i must be doing it
right because look at all the money that
i have so if i have like i made this
case um uh in a in a video not too long
ago about uh joe rogan for example
joe rogan is worth a hundred million
dollars that's what he was sold uh his
youtube channel for over to spotify for
and so no matter what joe does
100 million dollars covers a lot of sins
right it doesn't matter what he does
well hey he's got a hundred million
dollars so who cares right it doesn't
matter if he completely turns you know
does a 180 on whatever i don't expect
him to do that but if he did
people would just say well he's got he
must be doing something right because
he's got 100 million dollars
and i think that when you apply that to
intersectional dynamics when you apply
that to a guy like jeff bezos for
example right it's like who care like
this is a guy who could
have
a new chick every night of the week if
he wanted to he could have a just this
non-stop stream this line of escorts
waiting to go bang him any night he
wants to and yet who does he choose
to be in his life after his divorce with
mackenzie business
lauren sanchez
and why is that i use that as the
thumbnail for today's today's uh today's
topic but the reason for that is because
the guys like that are insulated it's
almost like uh it's almost like a really
good looking girl doesn't understand why
why things work for her right or if
you've got a girl who is um who doesn't
understand why men aren't attracted to
her because she has a degree she's got
her own business and she's got all this
stuff you can't really tell her
like
you know the reason why guys don't want
to get with you is because you spent all
this time
building up this sort of career and this
ego and and this money and this this
power base that you think should be
attractive you can't tell them that and
the truth of the matter is she spent all
this time do you know focusing on just
being that career alpha female
and now she doesn't understand why guys
don't aren't attracted to it it's kind
of like an analogous situation for
analogous situation for um for guys like
uh who are ultra wealthy guys who don't
understand the basics of of women who
don't understand female nature won't
even really understand their own nature
and to go and say you're a blue pill
beta you know you are that you don't
understand you you're going to be taken
to the cleaners because you don't have a
fundamental understanding of your own
nature women's nature and the game that
you've been in
the you know money is wealth whatever
even status power whatever is not an
insulation against blue pill thinking
just like you're saying like always
looking at this uh this tweet here rich
like that's the
that's the level of dedication these
guys have
to that blue pill train that blue blue
pill conditioning right they they don't
care about anything other ready to cut
you off and kick you out and unfriend
you and everything else because that
virtue signaling means more to them than
any kind of networking that they could
have with you i want a little bit deeper
on this one because i mean the thing
that's interesting about most these guys
that have created these businesses uh
like you know you've got got
granted you know i've never met jeff
bezos elon musk uh you know paige
ellison buffett zuckerberg like none of
these guys gates um
you know but the thing that's
interesting about these guys and the
ones that i can specifically say that
i've met personally is they're very good
at their craft like there is absolutely
no question that their high net worth
and
individuals um what's the other sound
bite we hear a lot about like high value
man there's a lot of guys out here out
there today beating their chest calling
themselves high value men who are
nowhere even closer but these guys are
legitimately
those people you know they've they've
created incredible businesses um and
done wonderful things for the world and
improve the status of the world for us
all you know the world that we live in
and it's like they've done that because
they've thought outside of the box if
steve jobs didn't think was like he
didn't even like have outside of the box
thinking steve jobs had not even seen
the box thinking
gate same thing with zuckerberg same
thing with bezos same thing with musk
like if you follow their biographies
like if you read any of their
biographies and i've covered about nine
out of ten of them there i've read them
all personally or either listen to them
they've they've all been outside of the
box thinkers they've unplugged from the
world of business you know they've
unplugged from the world of making money
but i'm a great race car driver
why can't i play chess why can't i rap
well well well it's not quite the same
thing because i mean like race car
driver in chess is two slightly
different you know genres but well it's
like women and money but why can't they
on well money's different you know you
know it's unplugging from lies you know
it's unplugging from just go get the job
you know clock in do your work clock out
be a good droid you know get your uh
casio watch when you [ __ ] retire and
go home and shut up and you know collect
your pension i'm talking about
unplugging from societal lies and
conventional norms because that's really
what i see you know the red pill and
unplugging as you're unplugging from
just be a nice guy you know bend the
knee to her happy wife happy life and
all that sort of [ __ ] dude
why can't they unplug from those lies
and and and see the sexual marketplace
and women for what it really is that's
what i find really interesting because
they're so good at it with creating a
business and and solving those problems
but they're unwilling to look at the
code in the matrix for what it is well
do you think he would have [ __ ] on you
rich if he knew you were wrong he would
just be like whatever and shrug it off i
don't and i got a theory that i don't
think these guys think you're wrong i
don't think that they are so deluded
with their blue pill life that they'll
fight it off i think
there's a part of them that knows this
is right you're not wrong
but there's like an impotence to it
there's like an admission let's say
you're 40 years old made your middle oh
yeah there's lots of guys that like dm
me after the fact like hey you're not
wrong but why are you talking about
these things like why are you practicing
but you know what it is you're not
asking them to accept this stuff what
you're saying is i want you to admit
that your last 40 years when it came to
women were a waste and i think a lot of
guys especially money-making champions
that got tons of ego
you're asking them to take a big step
outside of their ego and they've worked
very hard at that ego and they've earned
that ego and it's like who the [ __ ] are
you to tell me i'm wrong and i know it's
a weird self-sabotaging way to go about
it but like we're just meat brained
monkeys
with slightly higher iqs than bonobos
right and my my bank account
affirms everything that i do so yeah by
admitting this it must be right i wonder
if i can get to the point where they've
got so much money what else is throwing
money at it to solve the problem
yeah you know i can't get a girl to stay
where is it i'll just keep buying [ __ ]
or i'll put it up
the joke when bezos got divorced like
for to the tune of like what 33 billion
dollars was like
it cost him 33 billion for his divorce
and he's still the richest guy in the
world yeah there's still you know
there's still people that say you know
that um jeff and bill got divorced to
dodge taxes and i don't know maybe
there's some tax might be some truth no
maybe but i don't know that that's a
good strategy well i
even if it's if whether it's true or
it's not true i would also argue that
like i think a lot of these guys carry
that blue pill understanding of women
from their previous lives over into
their very rich lives
so it's like there's a there's a
qualifiable difference between somebody
like like bill gates or jeff bezos and
somebody who has
like played the game or maybe he came
into money and then he developed that
money um and and it understands and can
play and understands women's nature in
his own nature as well but if you look
at a guy who has sort of come from like
you know a computer background or a
coding background and they were once
beta but then they became very very rich
and they're still basically rich betas
they have such an insulation and such a
resistance to listening to anything else
because they're basically just focusing
on one thing which is whatever is going
to make the money that's that's the bill
gates you know plan for success is just
like be single-minded about one thing
and go straight ahead and then what gets
me is later on in life then you have
these we have these guys who want to
give you like these phil they become
suddenly become philosophers of life
like here's my secret to success and
it's like you have don't have the lived
experience to really be talking about
like how women are and how men are i
read this uh somebody sent me a quote
right right before this show um about uh
warren buffett i think it was in his
autobiography or something like that
where he was talking about his wife that
he he met and i think he got married to
her within like the first like
like two months of meeting her or
something i'm not i don't know exactly
the whole thing but he was he's very he
moons over her and it's like oh i just
knew she was the one first thing and
it's like wow this guy this is warren
buffett who is essentially reinforcing a
lot of these blue pill beta things i
think rich one of the things that that
was rubbing your your guys the wrong way
is
making it public because if you go and
you say something like that and you do
it on a big stage
that's their brand and so when women see
something like that or guys who are
still plugged into the matrix see
something like that it's almost like
maybe i'm wrong in this but like i
wonder how many of their wives or
girlfriends yeah exactly how much of
that is is like trying to sort of make
their necessity a virtue like yeah i
think so it's absolutely that is
it's absolutely that isn't it and also
just i think what you said before
about um
you know focus i mean i think a lot of
these guys if you look at zuckerberg for
example i mean you know he wasn't really
out playing the field was he i mean he
was you know he was a sort of geeky guy
coda or whatever and then he you know
developed facebook and i mean i my sense
is probably with these guys they're so
single-mindedly focused on the thing
that created their wealth that they just
don't really have a lot of experience
it's not so much that they're not
intelligent or they can't they're not
perceptive enough to understand some of
this stuff it's just they just probably
just don't look at it you know they have
they have a girlfriend who becomes a
wife or whatever and it's just not a
massive part of their life to to really
sort of analyze or or interrogate
you